foreign
Believe It or Not Thanksgiving is just
over a week away marking the start of
the holiday travel season almost 55
million people are expected to travel
one way or the other AAA projects it
could be the third busiest Thanksgiving
travel season since they started keeping
track more than 20 years ago in the
busiest since 2019. Chris Van Cleave is
at Reagan National Airport look and fly
as The Travelers Get Ready To Fly
well good morning in fact this airport
could be the busiest it's been in years
AAA expects what was a summer of Revenge
travel to continue right into the
holidays as for many people it's been
years since they've been able to
celebrate with their families but still
with inflation soaring some tell us
their travel plans have been grounded
do you want some cucumbers normally
Sharon herreri would be getting ready
for the annual Thanksgiving family
fly-in nearly two dozen relatives
meeting somewhere in the country to
celebrate the holiday together bikes are
too expensive but this year surging
airfare prompted herreri to postpone her
trip it's sad that I'm not going to be
you know with
um
my sisters and my brother and my mom and
they'll all be together I am going to
miss everybody
but hopefully I will see them in January
when I come visit
and we'll be together then it's a bummer
still AAA expects nearly 55 million
people will travel this Thanksgiving
that's up 1.5 percent from last year and
nearly back to pre-pandemic levels the
vast majority will drive
but air travel is forecasted to jump
nearly 8 percent and with cruise lines
back in business AAA predicts Cruise Bus
and Train travel will jump 23 percent
over last year the desire for people to
get back together with loved ones
they're going to do it no matter what
the cost they're going to budget in
other areas of their life but travel
doesn't appear to be one of them but
it's not just the turkey that will cost
you more this Thanksgiving
gas prices are about 36 Cents a gallon
higher than a year ago that's up about
10 percent according to NerdWallet car
rentals are a bit cheaper than last year
but have climbed 47 since October 2019
and hotels are up six percent from last
October airfare last month Rose 3.5
percent over September and was up 43
compared to last October I used all my
points and it was around 670 dollars for
the round trip play which is crazy
um without my points it would have been
well over a thousand dollars but college
student Alexandra Cohen who hasn't been
home since last year says the extra cost
is worth it I want to go home to see my
family for the holidays and be with them
and it's so so so expensive to just be
able to do that
now airports across the country are
warning they expect to run out of
parking spaces and are encouraging
people to reserve their space ahead of
time the busiest day to drive expected
to be Wednesday the day before
Thanksgiving and just yesterday the
Department of Transportation announced
it had helped Airline Flyers get about
600 million dollars in Airline refunds
the airline the dot rather issued fines
to six Airlines for not making those
refunds happen fast enough Nate
all right Chris and by looking fly I
just meant you're looking good today
that was it thank you
that's cool of course of course man have
a good one Chris